[Music]
it's finally time to set up my Nintendo
switch now that I have my mood lighting
I actually made a Nintendo switch
lighting setting like I'm that freaking
crazy now you see it now you don't right
there time to step this up
[Music]
[Applause]
always telling me to do something we
better do it it says so in my unboxing
video I called it the Nintendo switch
switcher converter something but
apparently it's just called the Nintendo
switch top set my icon I'm definitely
gonna be KK slider
yeah it's me me well I guess I should
insert my game card I'm just glad that
this setup video didn't take very long
because now that means I get to actually
care play its amaz Elda so I'll see you
guys later
just getting a much on you so you may
have already seen the joy Khan
controllers in my unboxing video but
here they are just in case you haven't
seen that they're pretty cool very small
so they definitely take a little bit of
getting used to so that's basically
three ways to play Nintendo switch right
now I'm playing on my big-screen TV you
can use the joy Khan controllers just
like this free one in each hand you can
also connect it to this controller and
make yourself one big controller and
then the third way is the tablet way cuz
you can just play here with this tablet
look down this little kickstand and you
can set it on your desk can you see that
see though that's pretty far away I can
still play using this controller I can
also play with these separated I can
also play with these connected to
so there's really so many different ways
to actually play this so depending upon
your preferred gameplay style that's
probably what's gonna be best for you
for me I'm always on the go so I'm
probably gonna play it like this quite
often it does charge using USBC so it'll
be pretty easy to find yourself an
external battery charger so if you are
on the go some reviews that I've seen
they said that you get about three hours
if you're playing Zelda breath of the
wild handheld style but using any type
of Mophie that uses USBC you'll pretty
much be set to go and you can play as
long as your battery doesn't run out so
thank you to Tendo for making this USBC
oh so excited so that completes my setup
here of the Nintendo switch I also told
you in my previous unboxing video if you
haven't seen that yet feel free to go
check it out that I would give you a
little office tour to explain kind of
what's going on behind me a lot of stuff
a lot of cords a lot of cables and yes I
know my cable management sucks every
done it so many times and then as soon
as I plug something else and it's just
the kids just so over here at this
lovely desk I have my Mac editing
station this is actually just my MacBook
Pro which is over here I have it
connected just using it firewire
converter so that I can use this mac
monitor I've got a Starbucks because
clearly how do I survive so let's re do
almost all of my video editing and now
I'll take you guys over here hi
can you still hear me I was too lazy to
move the camera this is my PC station
this is where I play PC games and also
other console games that I have below
there are psvr hiding down here got the
PC microphone Mac Pro that is basically
useless now it's just basically a very
nice decorative something that looks
like a water heater PC monitor here
console gaming monitor here and this one
sometimes is basically just
an extra monitor for whatever I might
need I've also got my NES classic back
here since most of the games that I play
are first-person shooter games it's so
hard to play those and be accurate on a
huge screen so with these tiny monitors
there's no latency so you'll be way more
precise and accurate so I just recently
decided to bring this TV and from a
guest bedroom that I have because I love
playing Nintendo games on a big screen
so I just wanted to sit here relax and
play Zelda until my eyes fall out so
that's my plan hope you guys enjoyed
this quick little office tour I do have
a 360 office tour up if you want to
check that out I'll also put a link in
the description since I posted that
video my office has got a lot more messy
I've got a few new additions so
basically all of the info is still
technically the same so I'll see you
guys later
that's it bye I'm gonna play switch I'm
gonna play switch once you switch
[Music]